you're not
I think
okay so
um welcome everyone to the extraordinary
meeting of the finance and projects
committee today the 9th of May
um the live stream is on
um welcome to those on live stream who
are joining us
today
um
so in terms of apologies there's no
apologies that I have for the committee
um so I can either move around a
secondary for that please accept the
apologies of none there's none okay I
won't do that
um we had Ria didn't we from the
previous she's not on the committee oh
okay but yeah
um and there is a major laid Autumn
which is about rugby park seismic
upgrade which we will cover in public
excluded
um
so can I have a move in a second to
receive that late paper thanks Darren
so yeah move Darren's second I think
Alex was first up yeah
oh Leslie right okay
right okay all those in favor
um scared
okay so the first item oh well the next
item sorry is the business enhancement
program projects dashboard so two
motions up there three motions
all right okay right okay sorry
um yeah quarter
quarter three performance sorry we'll
just item four
days
how are you welcome
um
thank you chair so I'll um I'll speak
briefly to the non-financial performance
and then hand to Patricia to summarize
the financial performance
um
so I think there are a few highlights
from the third quarter um the first of
those is obviously the delivery of the
second project within the road map to
Renewal so that's now two projects
within the pro whole program that are
complete
um and 25.6 million of the total
145.9 million that's been expended in
the service level performance there
hasn't been a great deal of change since
the last quarter we will see some of
this change further in the fourth
quarter is the final annual results come
in for those kpis that are only
delivered annually
um
there's one good news story the public
toilets now are on target to deliver
their performance after
um arrival of parts for some of the Eco
news
um passenger transport numbers do remain
down there is
no real change in the trend however we
are holding a workshop with the public
next week to discuss further about
public transport and what people want
ideas and things so that will hopefully
reveal more based on the resident survey
last quarter
and um
speaking briefly to the results of the
resident survey I think it's now
becoming obvious where the methodology
change of moving from a primarily
phone-based survey to an online survey
that we spoke about at the beginning of
the financial year it's becoming more
clear as the online results come through
and so that might be something to
consider as part of the ltp changing
some of the baselines but I think the
main message is that the core Services
of council remained strong good delivery
of all the water services
um and yeah I'll pass to Patricia to
talk about financial performance
thanks Ryan
um in terms of financial we're three
quarters of the way through the
financial year at this stage
um while on the face of it it looks like
the financial performance bottom line is
much worse you've got to remember that
there was a significant amount of
additional depreciation for the year
thanks to the asset revaluations so when
we take that out the performance that
we're forecasting for year end is pretty
much right on budget right on what the
annual plan budget was we look at the
nine months and
we're slightly better
um than what we thought we would be
um
just because of just the timing of how
things going through
um the capital program is well through
the spend and that
is
um
well the forecast has dropped again so
we're now forecast delivery of 53.2
million for the year
um that spend is sort of getting into
line with that but that as you recall
last year was the
previous Financial year was the biggest
Capital year that we had done
that's now looking to be similar coming
into this year thanks to some of the big
projects finishing and a number of big
projects still being there
we also have a number of forecast
changes which we would like to recommend
to council that they put in this is just
to ensure that we lined up the forecast
um to
because some of them go into early years
as well
like I said so just to clarify the other
forecasts
changes on page six of four books
that's a summary of them they um are in
further on yeah yes
okay so questions
so we've got ringy
yeah
thank you cheer look I just want to go
to the capital expenditure my activity
group and go straight to Solid Waste now
we had figures that um
infrastructure earlier this month that
nothing aligns seriously it doesn't
reflect accurately icc's curbside
collection volumes which ultimately uh
what we pay our rates on everything else
that goes to the transfer station
independently is paid for at the gate
and Commercial suppliers to a b lime
they pay separately as well so look as
chair of infrastructure I have got no
idea what's happening in this field it
shows a dramatic reduction in solid
waste last year was a dramatic increase
this is this is a roller coaster and it
even looking at the figures last earlier
this month in infrastructure they did
not align with our
2021 2022 financial report so that there
doesn't seem to be consistency with the
figures and the figures and volumes
ultimately turn into Cash
so look I
I just like I don't know something to
happen that actually shows us where we
are what we're doing accurately rather
than like every time I open a report on
solar waste it's it's like you know it's
a surprise
so I don't know what we can do or can
someone give me an answer
so just just to clarify so your your
query is around the volume variance it
is and they and the volumes are
ultimately reflected in in money terms
because yes yeah I understand that but
primarily you're talking about the
volume variance correct and the variance
between what's reported here and what's
reported in infrastructure and and also
in our financial reports and everywhere
it just there's there's no there seems
to be no consistency
in what in what formula is being used
because curbside collection is one
specific thing and that's a critical
thing yeah where the variance is along
with the contamination rate coming out
of recycling they're the two things that
gauge what our cost is
now you know okay if we got any response
from staff ability
through Mr chair there is
um the infrastructure GM is enter
available today but I think it is
certainly something that we've got the
message it will go back and I expect
there will have to be a report on
how this is calculated and two it's
going to have to explain why there is
such a variance between our documents
and you're quite right councilor you
have pointed this out
at different times in a different
capacities
um so it's something that staff are
going to have to address I mean I don't
mind can you know doing this continually
but yeah yeah it gets a Victorious and
within that we'll also include an
explanation of how that
um wastenet Works in relation to council
numbers as well because they are yeah
well that's
thank you thank you
just
a couple of questions really about
the resident survey the
um
I couldn't sleep last night so I read it
all
um
I noticed that
people have commented that it's a very
blunt instrument or that's my
interpretation sorry
um
there's no I don't know for instance
um responses to her wakateria or Splash
Palace or the library if people don't
use them but they feel compelled to
comment and
um I didn't find it helpful because some
of the comments you know if you don't
use the bus service
and you've never used the bus service
then should you be commenting on the bus
service and I don't mean that in a
disrespectful way to rape because I mean
how can you evaluate how good or not it
is if you don't by choice use it
um and if you never go to haywakatua but
oh it's not as good as having
um the real Museum or whatever if you
haven't been into it what is your
experience of it it's none
according to what I read
um it would feel that people didn't seem
to have and I don't know or I don't use
a server sort of option
and perhaps that could be part of the
survey mechanism please don't answer
this question if you don't use this
service or you know
um to stop some of the fill the space
comments that I felt that I was reading
that's the nature of the surveys isn't
it that each of those sort of random
comments were on a better term but at
least people responding as well
so any other questions before I start
so I've got a few so just with respect
to paid by board books you've got to
comment in the contractor response times
the non-urgent inquiries was a concern
what's
sorry which page it's page two or four
on your report
on board box page five
of them of the main report or the
performance report attachment sorry oh
just so I can find your report of the
main report
so the scene is water stormwater surge
activities were performing well with the
only measure concern related to the
contract response time to nod and Urgent
and chorus so this is the same issue as
the previous quarter and it's relating
to call out targets which are to be
responded to within a certain period of
time it's sitting very slightly outside
that period of time and that's relation
to the contractor response and
availability and they are actively
managing it
um but it is currently sitting slightly
outside the time window
but it's not a great deal of difference
but it is sitting slightly outside but
they are actively managed they are
actively managing it yes because
non-urgent can become urgent quite quick
and infrastructure
okay
um then in terms of on page
um
three or four and I think this is
probably you Patricia or someone in
terms of the forestry we we have people
advising us around cutting and all that
yes we do I can't yeah
um the 91 million
expenditure for nine months
is it possible to see a breakdown of
that expenditure in more detail and
comparatives around you know the
variances to planned as opposed to just
reading a 91 million dollar
um line I think we need more insight in
terms of so that would come to a normal
finance and projects meeting as part of
the breakdown okay good that's good okay
the further down there subsidy Revenue
four million increase what's that
um that is actually primarily because we
hadn't fully forecast the better off
funding for Tisbury
wasn't actually in the annual class
because we didn't include it and we will
have met all the Milestones the current
projections from the team as we'll meet
all the Milestones by the um 30th of
June to recognize the full amount of
that okay so primarily that's central
government funding yeah okay thank you
and then
um point four on that same thing
subvention income is it meant to be
subdivision income no submission income
so tax prevention payments the council
had some a small number of income tax
losses during the year which they sold
onto um some of the trading companies oh
cool and then the next one
um change in FTE
you talk about a change in FTE there how
many
increase in employee expenses and
Crystal flicks changing current Staffing
structure
because we uh
Anderson and Staffing that's happened
during the year so we might have come in
and the ERT at the moment would be a
classic example there's more than what
we originally planned so we had an
increase in FTE
some places we've had increases in some
places we're sitting with higher than
planned vacancies but overall we're down
well at the moment okay
that one oh I'll just get one quick
question um looking at the level of
service
um on routing services
um I noticed it um
the target is you know as decreasing
annually and you've got it's not only
the number of crashes at one fatality 13
series would be quite good I think in my
view to to know if that's better than it
was last year or the year before and I
noticed that uh the the bottom four
piece of that section there is no
information
available I think is it what the gray
means that could be quite good I mean to
to see if you know what what's being
done here because we've spent a lot of
money rearranging things recently and
eroding Road speeds and things and so
it'll be quite good to know that we're
actually
having a positive effect in my view
whereas we don't have any answers no
there's nothing here to indicate that
that is the case yeah
and certainly take that feedback back to
the team and in the fourth quarter you
will see all of that information
um in the roading area much of the data
comes through the wakakatahi central
system and so that's not available for
reporting until it arrives but take the
feedback Back Road crashes yeah and
further to that point so if there's an
accident would we pull the information
out of the accident report that talked
to say Road quality or some of the sort
of things that we
um have potentially could impact around
that accident because I mean that is
intent for a number of reasons but we've
just got to stick to what we could have
changed if anything out of an accident
to prevent it
don't we so you know Road quality would
be a classic wouldn't it where there's
been a poor Road quality has led to an
accident
that's certainly my understanding that
the team works with the police on those
matters but I I would
I would but the roading manager could
certainly speak to that yeah bring that
information back and that would come
through infrastructure with this
committee infrastructure yeah cool okay
other questions
no okay so there being none we've got
three
um
approvals there so can I have a move in
a second to exceed that way Mr chair
thank you Leslie
thanks Barry
all those in favor all right against
carried
okay
thanks Rihanna
whatever next time
okay we need to now move into public
exclusive so can I have a move in a
secondary for us to do that thanks Barry
thanks ringy
move in second